cuando estudiamos ciencia es natural
categorizar un montón de cosas que son
inimaginablemente pequeñas cuando la
gente dice que algo está por ejemplo a
escala atómica o a escala molecular o
digamos hablamos de una proteína o
quizás de una célula uno suele agrupar
lo todo esto y pensarlas todas estas
como cosas muy muy pequeñas verdad ahora
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
tener una apreciación de que aunque
todas estas cosas son pequeñas hay en
realidad una gran diferencia en sus
tamaños y espero que que eso nos dé una
buena idea de qué tan complejo puede ser
el mundo de una célula verdad o cómo
puede tener toda esta maquinaria por
dentro o cómo puede ser en realidad un
ser vivo o una parte de un ser vivo muy
bien así que vamos a nuestra primera
escala lo que tenemos aquí del lado
izquierdo es una molécula de agua y
esencialmente está digamos esférica que
he pintado en color morado es un átomo
de oxígeno y estas dos esferas blancas
son
de hidrógeno muy bien entonces estamos
pensando que en la molécula de agua
tiene digamos un ancho de
aproximadamente 0 punto 275 nanómetros y
quizás sería importante recordar que un
nanómetro es una mil millonésima parte
de de metro muy bien entonces en
realidad estamos hablando de que esto es
una mil millonésima mil millonésima
parte de un metro de un metro eso es un
número sumamente pequeño verdad es más
incluso podríamos tratar de observarlo
con milímetros por ejemplo tenemos que
esto sería lo mismo que una millonésima
parte es decir uno dividido entre un
millón es una millonésima parte de un
milímetro verdad esto nuevamente nos da
al menos una idea un poquito más clara
de que tan pequeño es un nanómetro
verdad porque pues al menos un milímetro
podemos verlo
por ejemplo en una regla verdad entonces
habría que dividir una regla en un
millón de partes para poder ver un
nanómetro bueno definitivamente no lo
podemos ver verdad al menos me gusta
pensarlo así porque podemos ver un
milímetro y podemos ver o pensar estas
esta partición en un millón de partes
verdad así que bueno esto es
definitivamente sobrepasa mis
capacidades de visualización pero bueno
esencialmente este sería el ancho de una
molécula de agua ahora vámonos a una
escala un poco más grande verdad vamos a
la siguiente escala y la siguiente
escala tiene que ver con proteínas
verdad aquí tenemos a nuestra amiga la
hemoglobina la hemoglobina es una
proteína y ésta tiene más o menos un
ancho de 5 nanómetros muy bien entonces
nuevamente estamos hablando de una
cantidad muy pequeña pero que
definitivamente es mucho más grande que
la de la molécula del agua es más de
hecho aquí he dibujado antes una digamos
un pequeño esbozo de nuestra molécula de
agua que teníamos del lado izquierdo
y aquí es digamos si estamos viendo de
este tamaño a la proteína así se vería
la molécula de agua así que en realidad
podemos ver que esta molécula de agua
verdad podemos ver que en realidad hay
un cambio dramático de escala y por
supuesto estamos pensando en una
complejidad mucho más grande cuando
hablamos de una proteína verdad de hecho
ya hemos hablado de la estructura de las
proteínas y de cómo pueden adoptar
digamos estas formas tan interesantes de
hacer cosas tan complejas en sistemas
biológicos vámonos a otro ejemplo
vámonos a ver este que es un virus y
este es un virus muy conocido verdad es
el vih el virus de la inmunodeficiencia
humana verdad y por supuesto este tiene
digamos un ancho de 120 nanómetros
aproximadamente así que por ejemplo aquí
lo que podemos tener podemos comparar
aquí con nuestra proteína que teníamos
anteriormente la hemoglobina y podemos
ver que en realidad tiene un tamaño muy
pequeño comparado con este virus verdad
definitivamente ahora si la molécula de
agua no se observaría en este
en esta comparación muy bien así que aún
aun así el tamaño de un virus es muy
pequeño verdad estamos hablando de 120
millones y más partes de un milímetro es
decir 120 mil millonésimas partes de un
metro esto es sumamente pequeño ahora si
nos vamos a la siguiente escala podemos
aquí observar a ésta
esta célula en azul que tenemos aquí
esta es una célula t es una célula t muy
bien y quizás también puedas observar
claramente qué es lo que tenemos del
lado izquierdo y lo que tenemos aquí en
azul es exactamente esta misma célula t
pero en amarillo lo que podemos observar
digamos aquí estas estas digamos bolitas
amarillas que se observan en nuestras
células es el mismo virus que tenemos
del lado izquierdo es el vih verdad que
en dónde está tomando ventaja de la
célula t para poder reproducirse y por
eso no sé yo siento que esta imagen es
algo horripilante de verdad pero bueno
aquí podemos comparar sus tamaños verdad
aquí podemos comparar el tamaño del
virus
del vih con respecto al tamaño de la
célula t verdad ahora por supuesto aquí
la hemoglobina ya no se alcanza a
distinguir verdad ahora dentro de la
misma escala tenemos estas células rojas
verdad las son las células de la sangre
verdad y aquí estamos haciendo una
comparación con microscopio electrónico
entre una célula roja que tenemos de
este lado y una célula te quedés de la
que estábamos hablando hace unos
momentos y podemos decir que a groso
modo verdades son del mismo tamaño
verdad
de hecho la célula roja verdad está esta
célula roja tiene un ancho de
aproximadamente 6 a 8 micrómetros ahora
que es un micrómetro bueno por ejemplo
digamos el promedio son 7 verdad lo que
tenemos aquí estamos hablando de 7
millones y más partes verdad de 1 metro
y aquí por supuesto cuando hablábamos
del nanómetro estamos hablando si de una
millonésima parte pero ahora de un
milímetro verdad y el milímetro era una
milésima parte de metro y por eso
decíamos que un nanómetro es una
millonésima parte de un metro aquí sólo
estamos hablando de siete millones y más
partes de un metro que sigue siendo un
tamaño sumamente pequeño verdad de hecho
por ejemplo para hacer la comparación
con la hemoglobina verdad la hemoglobina
es una proteína que está presente en
todas las células rojas verdad y se
estima que hay aproximadamente 280
millones de lobinas dentro de cada una
de estas células rojas es es un número
muy grande de proteínas verdad quiere
decir que este está esta proteína es
sumamente pequeña comparada con el
tamaño de la célula roja verdad así que
espero que esto te empiece a dar una
intuición de que aunque por ejemplo
categorizamos las células como algo
inimaginable mente pequeño de hecho son
mucho más grande es verdad incluso
enormes comparados con cosas como
proteínas y con todo lo que se encuentra
por ejemplo a una escala molecular o por
ejemplo atómica por eso las células son
tan interesantes incluso son muy
complejas y podemos decir que hay todo
un mundo dentro de ellas verdad de hecho
por ejemplo no sé si pensamos en el
ancho de un cabello humano pensamos en
el ancho de un cabello humano y si lo
pintamos a una escala por ejemplo de
estas células entonces más o menos el
ancho de todo este vídeo más o menos el
ancho de todo este vídeo sería el ancho
de un cabello humano si lo pintamos
digamos comparándolo con estas células
rojas verdad eso es una comparación muy
muy muy interesante verdad ahora por
supuesto que se vería mucho más grande
nuestro cabello si consideramos la
escala de la hemoglobina o mucho más si
comparamos con la molécula del agua es
más te invito a que tomes uno de tus
cabellos y lo observes con detenimiento
ponlo en una hoja de papel y piensa que
estamos diciendo que las células
de este tamaño verdad se verían de este
tamaño comparado con el ancho del
cabello que corresponde al ancho del
vídeo así que puedes ver que cada uno de
estos de estas imágenes es un mundo en
sí mismo por ejemplo cuando pensamos en
escalas moleculares o en escalas virales